mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour aujourd'hui dimanche 15 février
les titres et bien à paris le manifeste
du parti radical a été adopté à
l'unanimité moins une voix
l'interview du président nasser un
hebdomadaire américain la course de cet
après midi à auteuil c'est dire le
tiercé annulé tout de suite du sport
avec jean-michel leulliot du ski à val
gardena cbi liquide 2 n'est ce pas qui a
remporté l'épreuve
non je crois que vous viviez d'erreur
parce qu'il ya le classement a été
modifié a failli aussi que des jeunes
qui sont partis en 2e série c'est à dire
après le dossard numéro 15 on était dans
le clan de tête en tout cas c'est une
grande surprise puisque c'est le suisse
bernard russie qui remporte cette
descente et c'est une grande déroute
pour les français bernard russie en 2
minutes 24 secondes des 57 centièmes de
quelques centièmes de secondes vous
allez le voir d'ailleurs le voici avec
le juge qui agite son drapeau
il était parti avec le dossard numéro 15
sur cette piste qui était longue de 3750
mètres 801 m de dénivellation 26 forte
de direction il faisait moins huit
degrés le temps était couvert et il n'y
aurait tout au long de la piste tout au
long des 3750 mètres près de 12000
spectateurs une grande surprise donc à
victoire de russie que l'on disait dilué
par une créature à la manette tout avait
été arrangée il faut croire du noir
attend puisque russie avait déjà réussi
de très très bonnes performances dans
les descentes et on considérait
d'ailleurs avec l'autrichien karl
coordin comme l'un des adversaires les
plus dangereux des français bien les
français aujourd'hui ont très mal joué
car ils sont très très loin comme ne va
vous montrer les façons je dors et dans
quelques secondes de 24,79 c'était le
temps de coordination avec le dossard
numéro 3 aussi réussir à 2 24 57 c'est à
dire 22 centièmes de seconde de mieux
premier bernard russie deuxième karl
cording 22 centièmes je voulais dit
troisième maicon mind l'australien craig
annie la descente de val d'isère qui est
entraînée par bob wollek le français
ancien champion du monde universitaire à
52 centièmes quatrième karl schranz que
l'on attendait aussi puisqu'il avait
réussi meilleur temps dans la non stop à
89 centièmes 5e deux ex-aequo un
étonnant varallo parti avec le dossard
23 italiens 95 centièmes à égalité de
temps avec bill kid que vous citiez tout
à l'heure bernard à 95 centièmes
également voyez donc
il y à cet homme dans la même seconde
ensuite andy arrive à 99 centièmes vous
allez me dire où sont les français et
bien jean-luc pinel est 9e à deux
secondes neuf centièmes
henri duvillard 21e à 4 secondes 33
centièmes au recel
27e à 6 secondes et russell qui perd sa
place du combiné au bénéfice de kid et
29e à plus de 9 secondes grande déroute
les français l'ont expliqué en parlant
de fartage mais cela quand même
n'explique pas tout merci l'actualité
politique maintenant aujourd'hui se
déroule le deuxième tour des élections
municipales de nancy nous en reparlerons
ce soir tout ce que l'on sait ce matin
c'est que la participation n'a pas été
très forte le combat extraordinaire du
parti radical je vous le disais tout à
l'heure s'est prononcé en fin de matinée
sur le manifeste présenté par
jean-jacques servan-schreiber c'est
daniel prime qui va nous faire le compte
rendu de cette dernière séance avoue
dernier point
le congrès du parti radical vient de
s'achever
il était 11 heures lorsque les
congressistes en voter sur le manifeste
de monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber ce congrès s'achève par
la victoire de monsieur maurice faure et
de monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber puisque c'est à
l'unanimité moins une voix que le
manifeste a été adoptée cette nuit une
commission des résolutions avait siégé
et avait examiné un certain nombre
d'amendements à apporter au texte compte
tenu de tous les exposés qui avait été
entendu cet après midi monsieur maurice
port a longuement pris la parole pour
expliquer les amendements eux mêmes et
pour indiquer qu'il ne remettait pas en
cause le fond de ce qui avait été écrit
et il a été entendu par le congrès
puisque je viens de vous dire ce texte a
été voté à l'unanimité disons que les
amendements apportés l'ont été à propos
notamment du service militaire qui vous
le savez est supprimé dans le manifeste
il y a eu là un certain nombre de
précisions il ya eu un certain nombre de
précisions
en ce qui concerne également les
libertés individuelles et tout ce qui
pourrait ne pas figurer par écrit dans
ce texte
et il y a eu également énormément de
précision en ce qui concerne la
transmission du pouvoir héréditaire
vous allez du reste pouvoir entendre la
fin du discours de monsieur maurice
faure mais notre ambition doit être à la
mesure de nos moyens c'est à dire de ce
qui relève de la politique la politique
ne peut pas changer ce qui est
physiologique au congénitale la
politique peut changer un peu mais pas
totalement ce que j'appelle la
discrimination des premières années mais
par la suite elle doit changer tout ce
qui est en son pouvoir d'abroger comme
causes fondamentales inégalité des
chances entre les jeunes
elle doit s'élever contre les primaires
et sur ce point je le disais hier
affirmer que c'est le mérite et pas la
naissance qui doit être à la base du jeu
du libre jeu dans la vie et moi je
croise à la valeur et morale économique
de ce formidable dynamisme qui à chaque
génération brasse à nouveau les chances
et les risques qui est à la fois
créateur et destructeur c'est possible
mais qui donne une civilisation et une
dimension et une direction et une morale
c'est de la maine radicaux que se
manifeste vous propose
mais si vous nous écoutez alors
l'histoire retiendra sans doute que
c'est vous aujourd'hui qui aurait initié
la voie de l'avenir avant demain de le
conduit
conséquence du mauvais temps en france
l'électricité n'est toujours pas rétabli
dans le nord cotentin l'edf ans
déclarent ne pas savoir exactement quand
l'électricité sera ramenée dans
l'électricité reviendra à paris incendie
dans un grand hôtel sur les champs
elysées incendie qui a éclaté hier à 13h
à l'hôtel le claridge avenue des champs
elysées n'a fait aucune victime mais des
dégâts assez importants
on pense que c'est dans une boutique de
parfumerie situé près de l'entrée que le
feu a pris
les pompiers ont dû évacuer à l'aide de
la grande échelle les occupants des
étages supérieurs clients et personnes
les flammes prenait rapidement de
l'importance puisque les marbres du
corridor se fendirent qu'en dit que les
rideaux du restaurant prenait feu à
14h15
l'incendié était maîtrisé
les autres informations interview du
président d'acer donc un quotidien
américain accepté le support aérien
direct depuis la soviétique ou étrangers
est une question délicate à laquelle je
dois réfléchir a déclaré le président
nasser dans l'interview qui publie
aujourd'hui simultanément par le new
york times et le journal cairote al
ahram
tout indique que le bombardement de
lusine d'abou zaabal qui a fait 70 morts
civils a été de la part d'israël
un acte terroriste un acte de terrorisme
prémédité a déclaré le président nasser
il n'y a aucun établissement militaire à
proximité de cette usine l'heure du raid
a été choisie pour coïncider avec le
changement des équipes de travail
voilà pour l'actualité de politique
internationale
en france un visiteur de marque qui va
rentrer dans son pays mardi il s'agit du
jeune prince hériter d'iran reza de son
frère et de sa soeur ses guitares tous
les cas suivi leur séjour à paris
venant de suisse où il venait de passer
des vacances d'hiver le prince héritier
d'iran le prince reza qui a 9 ans
accompagné de sa jeune soeur faranah et
jean petit frère ali arrivé mercredi
dernier pour la première fois par ce
voyage de notre capitale était un désir
que le prince avait souvent manifesté et
qui se trouve aujourd'hui réalisées
le lendemain de son arrivée le prince et
la princesse visiter le palais de la
découverte
tour à tour intrigués curieux
enthousiastes le prince manifesté un
grand intérêt pour l'instrument
se promenant dans paris le prince eu la
chance de découvrir notre capitale
pendant les rares apparitions du soleil
rens est-ce que vous avez aimé paris
qu'avez vous vu
c'est sous la tour eiffel des toiles la
scène avec le palais de la découverte
et qu'est ce qui vous a plus
particulièrement celles à trois semaines
vous êtes monté
mais au deuxième étage
si le prince reza fut très intéressé par
le salon international du jouet le petit
prince ali cinq ans fut totalement
subjugué par ce qu'il découvrait mais
les jeunes
comment se fait-il que vous parlez si
bien français parce que dans mon pays at
euros je fais la classe de français et à
la maison avec mon père le maire je pars
souvent aussi les français quel livre
lisez-vous
les tailles les astérix avec d'autres au
livre vous aimez bien astérix oui
à l'école et quel est le programme de
vos études et c'est la géographie la
science observations je fais la lecture
la grammaire la tester et je fais aussi
un peu de cash qui est ça marche bien
l'école à la maison de l'iran en
inaugurant une exposition le dessin d'un
franc vers amiens en présence de
personnalités artistiques de paris il
faisait son apprentissage un prince un
apprentissage difficile canule à cette
nuit à l'hôpital d'argenteuil dans la
banlieue parisienne toutes les radios
ont annoncé la naissance de quintupler
on a même entendu des reportages
réalisés sur place l'hôpital a été
assiégé par les journalistes en fait il
s'agissait d'une plaisanterie de carabin
les quintuplés n'existe pas le
professeur barnard quant à lui n'a pas
n'a pas encore ce genre de problème vous
savez qu'il vient de se marier il y a
seulement quelques heures avec une
ravissante jeune femme de 19 ans les
deux jeunes mariés sont arrivés à rome
leur seul souci échapper aux
photographes la réunion hippique il
devait avoir lieu cet après midi à
auteuil est annulé il s'agit du tiercé
tiercé sera organisée jeudi c'est ce
qu'annonce la société des courses de
jean-michel à vous la parole pour la
suite with pour le reste de l'actualité
sportive des résultats de basket
puisqu'on joue souvent basket le samedi
soir de nimba pub 86,56 le mamba vichy
81 à 80 juan barre à 6 ans 3 à 85 et
antibes matelot 75 71 des autres
rencontres
aujourd'hui à louiseville je parle là de
l'athlétisme de réunion en salle aux
états unis le nom de mcgrady devient
célèbre maintenant dans tous les états
unis car il a battu et avant-hier ivan
champion olympique du 400 haies double
champion olympique du 800 il à réussir
la meilleure performance mondiale en
salle sur 600 yard sont une minute puis
secondes cinq dixièmes en boxe miloud
iai que vous allez voir il est noir il
était de poser amène est très fière a
été battu au 3e round sans surprise d'un
crochet du gauche au foie
c'est d'ailleurs un scandale d'opposer
de si faibles adversaires à les garçons
de talent comme et les traits qui n'ont
rien à prouver
en face deux boxeurs comme diane je
pense que vous avez peut-être vu
d'ailleurs les images du combat hier
soir à sallanches en football un arbitre
français
monsieur machin a été choisi pour
arbitrer des rencontres de coupe du
monde de football au mexique
j'aimerais vous dire également qu'en
rugby un match est remis bannière
graulhet il devait se jouer à bagnères
mais le match plus qu'à agen lui aura
bien lieu cet après midi à 15 heures à
charléty en hockey victoire de la france
aux championnats du monde dans sa poule
évidemment la france a battu l'as olemps
par 9 à 2 et en sport automobile bjorn
waldegard deux fois vainqueur de monte
carlo a triomphé au rallye de suède
voilà et en ce qui concerne le ski
j'aimerais signaler a ajouté qu'on
pourrait voir les images de la descente
cet après midi dans télé dimanche mais
enfin nexans chauny les dernières
vedette du disque sont deux perroquets
leur remettre leurs éleveurs est un
avocat du barreau de paris et le
reportage que vous allez voir ce sujet
et de fist irizar jacquotte ait pas
parce que dit-on en arrivant en jour oui
et si tu te trouves avec des anglais
jacquotte comment leur diras tu dis nous
bonjour en anglais jacques clôture à
coucher tout à l'heure tu te moques de
papa matra ours c'est je crois la
première fois que deux perroquets
enregistre un disque
eh bien oui et s'il enregistre c'est
parce que tous les deux jacquotte et ito
que voici ont gagné ensemble ils sont
premiers ex aequo le dernier championnat
du monde des oiseaux parleurs de même
qu'ils avaient gagné d'ailleurs les
trois championnats précédents jacquotte
tu veux faire des additions avec papa
allons-y un +23 très bien 3 + 5 et bien
3 et 1,3 oh non tu t'es trompé
après tu t'es trompé a réfléchi bien que
claude 3 et 1 tu t'emportes tromper ne
suffit pas de demander pardon
il faut réfléchir aux codes tu vas te
rattraper un 4 puces droit ça fait
combien cette quelle est votre méthode
cette méthode d'ailleurs je les expose
dans la première phase ii faites parler
votre père auquel mon 33 tours est
exactement la même méthode que nous
employons nous les humains pour élever
nos enfants
autrement dit associations du mot à
l'objet vous savez de cette association
est la clé du langage intelligents ainsi
jacote ito on a pris comme premiers mots
des mots concrets comme gâteau en
association avec l'image du gâteau
demande-moi d'imiter le sap qui crache à
yahoo demande moi de faire le pigeon
calpi gens auront à ton tour jacob quel
petit oiseau
quand tu es la deuxième phase de ce
disque c'est le récital de jacques côté
ito alors c'est l'heure c'est leur
programme de leur programme libre car
vous savez dans les championnats du
monde des oiseaux parleur il ya d
imposer et des libres comme en patinage
artistique les imposer se réalise devant
le jury devant les jurys internationaux
en dehors de la présence de l'éducateur
c'est à dire que les perroquets sont
interrogés par les membres du jury sont
des trois ans dit aux log et dans les
exercices fibre dans la salle festival
les perroquets présente ce qu'ils
veulent
imite le vert mais la radio cherche un
poste rassemblement dans la cour
hymne au drapeau de la légion au dodo
bonne nuit
chaque couche et voilà c'était notre
favori pour le championnat des
perroquets des celui de jean-michel le
hyundai merci de votre attention au
revoir